die üblichen nebenwirkungen die bei auch
anderen impfungen auftreten können wie
natürlich schwerer haben beide einander
einstichstelle daneben unter umständen
eben müdigkeit auch fieber kann durchaus
auftreten weil dieser impfung mit
astrazeneca impfstoff aber auch bei den
anderen impfstoffen die in europa
zugelassen werden hat man ähnliches
nebenwirkungsprofil wie wir das sagen
und durchaus auch sehr ähnlich zum
beispiel wie bei der influenza grippe
impfung oder bei der impfung gegen die
gürtelrose auch hier hat man durchaus
ähnliche nebenwirkungen ist nichts
besonderes tatsächlich dass man eben
auch mal ein fieber auch mein tag
durchaus sich krank fühlt es ist ja
eigentlich auch ein gutes zeichen denn
man merkt daran das immunsystem reagiert
auf diesen impfstoff auch dann
entsprechend immunität auf und man ist
dann eben geschützt dagegen dann muss
man das eben in kauf nehmen wie es auch
im beitrag geantwortet
genauer gesagt wurde eine erkrankung mit
corona es viel viel schlimmer als diese
durchaus zu ertragender nebenwirkungen
das sind halt auch nebenwirkungen die
durchaus eben bei diesen impfungen und
das betrifft eben nicht nur astrazeneca
sondern auch die anderen impfstoffe
durchaus beobachtet werden
man kann dementsprechend raten man kann
natürlich auch entsprechend zum beispiel
fiebersenkende medikamente paracetamol
zum beispiel einige symptome etwas
abzumildern
aber man muss grundsätzlich damit
rechnen tatsächlich das entsprechende
symptome wie sie gerade beschrieben
wurden auch auftreten können gesagt es
ist eigentlich eher ein positives
zeichen weil man eben meist man hat auch
entsprechende reaktion und auch leider
ist es natürlich so jüngeren menschen
reagieren auf solche impfstoffe häufig
etwas stärker als die älteren menschen
hat mit älteren immunsystem zu tun
das muss man halt leider in kauf nehmen
also ich würde den sofort nehmen wenn
kein anderer haben will weil hauptsache
ich bin hier um 75 prozent zu 90 prozent
was sagen die prozentzahlen aus da muss
man ja auch erstmal hinter steigen
ich werde mich dafür
wenn es nur erst rassen eger gebe denn
würde sich die diskussion ja nicht
stellen natürlich ich finde die impfung
wichtiger als die auswahl also meine
meinung mit einem masters-sieg das gibts
doch ist denn jetzt einige sagen sie
möchten den mit verwenden
dann wäre es einfach gut die übrigen
dosen klima hat und die nächsten risiko
künftig zudem dann können die auch
entscheiden will ich mit ihm zu lassen
aber ich würde mich auf jeden fall dann
mit dem lassen mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren